uh ireland's european commissioner
married mcginnis has said an order by
northern ireland's agriculture minister
to halt post-brexit checks on goods is
an absolute breach of international
law uh our senior island correspondent
david blevins is at the port of belfast
i think you've got some a potential
breaking news for us as well david
yes well we've always said this story is
not about trade it's about politics and
we understand now from cl sources close
to northern ireland's first minister
paul given that he has written his
letter of resignation and is preparing
to step down today so we are now
entering yet again a significant
political crisis in northern ireland
because that will render the devolved
government effectively
powerless
this is simply because the dup believes
the british government has run out of
road in its negotiations with the eu
around that border in the irish sea so
yesterday a dup minister flying solo
ordered a halt to brexit checks
at ports in northern ireland that was
against the wishes of the rest of the
so-called part of the power sharing
government so now what you have is the
dup going further in that you have the
dup first minister preparing to tender
his resignation now just to remind
people to avoid a border on this island
the british government and the eu agreed
that there would be a border established
in the irc instead many people will tell
you that that has been an economic boost
for northern ireland that unique access
to both the eu market and the gb market
but others particularly unionists will
argue that it's been an economic
disaster and has cost northern ireland
millions of pounds the reason for those
two conflicting positions as i say is
that this has never really been about
trade it's always been about politics
because that border in the irish sea
made unionists feel very anxious about
northern ireland's position as part of
the united kingdom so they really
believe it's night time to act and it is
our understanding just to repeat the
breaking news from sources close to the
first minister that paul given has
written his letter of resignation and is
preparing to step down at the helm of
northern ireland's devolved government
today remember we're just three months
away from an assembly election in
northern ireland we are now witnessing
the end of this administration